Madame aubrey,
pourquoi voter la France à soumise et pas le
participer à 10
par exemple aux actions européennes ?
Parce que on est aujourd'hui les héritiers,
les défenseurs du programme de la nupece.
Parce que aujourd'hui aussi, au niveau européen,
on ne donnera pas 1 seule voix au
système de congestion
qui fait que l'Union
européenne est gérée par les libéraux,
la droite et, euh.
Le parti socialiste et socio-démocrate.
Donc nous, on refuse,
euh. Ce système de congestion.
Qu'est-ce que vous dites aux jeunes qui s'abstiennent ?
On leur dit, euh, ne restez pas chez vous,
c'est le meilleur cadeau que vous pourriez faire à
Emmanuel Macron,
il n'attend que ça, que les jeunes ne se mobilisent pas.